Nevada in the meantime still has one of
the highest unemployment rates in the
entire country
now these SNAP program or food stamps is
seeing a surge in new applications are
Hector Mejia is live this morning with
how you can request assistance if you
need it good morning Hector good morning
Alex a lot of families are falling on
hard times right now the state says if
you or anyone you know is thinking about
applying for SNAP benefits well the best
thing to do is to apply online there's
also a pre-screening tool that allows
you to check if you qualify on average
we're told eligible applications will
get approved in about four days welfare
offices are open for those families who
need to apply but do not have internet
at home you will be asked for a proof of
income household size and citizenship
status and we've learned the state is
preparing for another increase in
first-time applications if you're
walking into this for the first time
like so many others in the valley
chances are you may not know what you're
actually allowed to buy with a snap card
so we asked a state agency that runs the
federal SNAP program for a little bit of
advice food item is taxable then you
cannot use your SNAP benefits to
purchase it so those are usually items
like things in the hot food case
fountain drinks pet food anything where
attacks can be charged then your SNAP
benefits cannot be used to pay for it
for some perspective about the need back
in April of the 20,000 new applications
60% of those were filed by people
applying for the first time before the
Cova 19 crisis back in January for some
comparison only 33% of the new
applications filed that month were
first-time applications and the program
is getting a little bit more flexible
Smith's earlier this year said they are
now allowed to take SNAP benefits as a
form of payment for pickup orders and
also Amazon and Walmart announced that
they can now take snap cards as a form
of payment as well for online orders
reporting live this morning Hector Mejia
8 news now